never before in history have there been
so many people on earth as right now
our numbers have skyrocketed from 1
billion in 1800 to 2.3 billion in 1940
3.7 billion in 1970 and 7.4 billion in
2016.
the world population increased fourfold
in the last century so what can we
expect for the next century
and what does population growth mean for
our future
will there be mass migration overcrowded
slums in mega cities covering continents
diseases and pollution chaos and
violence over energy water and food and
a human species focused only on
sustaining itself
will population growth destroy our way
of life or is this prophecy just
ungrounded panic
[Music]
in the 1960s population growth reached
an unprecedented rate
which led to apocalyptic prophecies
the poor would procreate endlessly and
overrun the developed world
the legend of overpopulation was born
but it turns out high birth rates and
the population explosion are not
permanent features of some cultures or
countries but rather part of a four-step
process the whole world is going through
the demographic transition
most developed countries have already
made the transition while other
countries are doing it right now
let's go back to the 18th century when
the entire world including europe was in
the first stage of the demographic
transition
by today's standards europe was worse
off than a developing region suffering
from poor sanitation poor diets and poor
medicine
a lot of people were born but lots of
them died just as fast so the population
hardly grew
women had between four and six children
but only two of them would reach
adulthood
then the industrial revolution happened
in the uk and brought the greatest
change in human living conditions since
the agricultural revolution
people went from being peasants to
workers
manufactured goods were mass-produced
and became widely available the sciences
flourished and advanced transportation
communication and medicine
the role of women in society shifted and
created the conditions for their
emancipation
slowly this economic progress not only
formed a middle class but also raised
standards of living and health care for
the poor working population
the second transition stage started
better food supplies hygiene and
medicine meant people stopped dying all
the time especially so at a very young
age
the result was a population explosion
doubling the uk's population between
1750 and 1850
the main reason families used to have
lots of children was that only a few of
them were likely to survive
now that had changed so the third stage
of the transition was set in motion
fewer babies were conceived and
population growth slowed down
eventually a balance emerged fewer
people were dying and fewer children
were born so the death rate and birth
rate became stable
britain had reached the fourth stage of
the demographic transition
this didn't only happen in the uk more
and more countries went through the four
stages
first many births and many deaths due to
bad living conditions second better
living conditions leading to fewer
deaths and a population explosion third
fewer deaths resulting in fewer births
and population growth came to an end
but if birth rates have dropped so much
why is the population still growing so
fast
well the children born in the population
explosion of the 70s and 80s are having
kids themselves now leading to a
noticeable spike in overall population
but they are having far fewer children
on average than their parents the
average today is 2.5 it was 5 40 years
ago
so as this generation gets older and
fertility declines further the rate of
population growth will keep on slowing
this is true for every country
in the west we tend to overlook progress
in other regions of the world
but actually most of the world's
countries have made it to the fourth
stage just look at bangladesh in 1971
the average woman had seven kids but 25
percent of them would die before the age
of five
in 2015 the mortality rate was down to
3.8 percent and women had only 2.2 kids
on average
this is the rule not an exception we're
not special we just had a head start
it took developed countries about 80
years to reduce fertility from more than
six children to less than three
others are catching up fast malaysia and
south africa did it in only 34 years
bangladesh took just 20. iran managed it
in 10 years
all these countries that are catching up
didn't have to start from scratch and
the more support they get the faster
they catch up
this is why programs that help lower
child mortality or help poor nations
develop are so important no matter what
your motivation is whether you dream of
a world where all people live in freedom
and wealth or you just want fewer
refugees coming to your country the
simple truth is that it's beneficial to
you personally if people on the other
side of the globe can live a good life
and we are getting there the percentage
of people living in extreme poverty has
never been as low as today
so the future of global population
growth is actually not an apocalyptic
prophecy at all it's a promise
population growth will come to an end
the un forecasts that the 12 billionth
human will never be born at all
and as the development level of the
world rises the number of people with a
higher education will increase tenfold
countries who used to be in need will
help advance development instead
more people is going to mean more people
able to advance our species
[Music]
this video was a collaboration with max
rosa and our world in data where he
explores the progress of humanity
through research and data visualization
make sure to check it out
in 2016 we were able to make more and
better content than ever before because
of your support on patreon.com thank you
so much and we'll be back in the year